[Music]
[Applause]
actor josh dumel is on the uh the phone
do you uh do you have a sad song josh
i do i do dan uh tim mcgraw
don't take the girl
johnny's daddy was taking him fishing
when he was eight years old
you remember that one
uh
i think i i think i remember it i'm i'm
trying to figure it out by listening to
you sing it but um that's don't take the
girl
it's really sad i mean i literally
listened to it a couple weeks ago and i
got a little tear in my eye
i'm gonna guess that's what a lot of
guys said to you don't take the girl
away from them
and you did
right
yeah let's go with that story um are you
so you're engaged now right so you took
the girls
i took the girl that's awesome and uh
and when are you getting married
i'm not telling you that you're invited
though
well you gotta tell me
when
when you're getting married i got to
make plans
you'll get a special invite yeah you're
on the dance oh okay a group effort
wow okay are we getting married in
north dakota
i can't tell you that dan you're gonna
have to wait to get the invite all right
will i need a passport to go
no okay no you won't all right you might
need some mosquito repellent though
oh it's north dakota here we come
i love it
uh you got a new show out don't you
coming up
i do you know i didn't i wasn't calling
for that reason but fritzy said hey
congratulations on the new show it's
like oh yeah that comes out tonight
everything's perfect
oh
i'm also i'm also going to be part of
the uh the march madness
tournament brackets right here the
celebrity bracket challenge
yeah who you got this year who's your
final four
i i don't know yeah i gotta do i gotta
do some research i gotta do some
homework
i i like gonzaga a lot i think gonzaga
is
the best team they might be better than
last year but
um yeah i gotta figure i gotta figure
this out here soon
do you watch so much college basketball
i
this time of the year yes yes i do i i
start i love championship week but last
week is when it felt like i did a little
bit deeper dive into this
um and you know watching north carolina
beat duke how good is duke are they
going to be a three seed now you know so
i gotta i mean i think i think he's
gonna use that i think they're gonna go
deep they might make the final four
might even win it i think they were
really
really pissed off with themselves for
not winning that basketball well they
should be they nearly gave up a hundred
points at home i mean that's about as
embarrassing as it gets by the way it's
josh dumel the new show is the thing
about pam and you didn't even ask for a
plug it's on peacock who is pam by the
way
pam hup is a woman from uh troy missouri
his base the whole thing came from a
dateline special
that went on to have this really popular
podcast afterwards the story itself is
is one of those that you wouldn't even
believe if it weren't true it's just
crazy what happened
um
and renee zellweger plays pam hop and
does an amazing job it's you know it's
very dark subject matter but the show is
actually kind of darkly funny it's got
that quirky sort of farthery feel i
think oh god
she kills it
wait literally
i literally killed
it well you said dateline and always
somebody ends up dying in dateline
yep
yes they do
i got to meet i got to meet keith
morrison by the way the other night and
what'd you think what'd you think oh
he's just like
hello josh
[Laughter]
princey does a pretty good impersonation
of uh keith morrison
remember the old lady living on the park
bench she was just sitting there minding
her business or was she
he certainly had a lot of information
for the dade county police department
you got to slow it way down fritzy yeah
todd can't slow it down
uh all right well hey i just wanted to
call and say hello to my boys hey
congrats on everything and uh and then
we look forward to the wedding
invitation
right i think i got purdue kentucky duke
and ucla in my final four
i think i think okay
all right i gotta go
all right
okay all right that's joshua
got engaged i think he he got engaged to
like uh miss america or somebody
you know that guy needed a break in life
yeah yeah glad he finally got it